hey everyone
the greatest illusions ego
time death fear and separation
ego and time are the two heaviest
anchors
holding people back from god slash
self-realization
really feel the heaviness of those
anchors
that permeate society the egoic
separate self entity
especially with the elongated pinocchio
nose
that is disturbing the planetary harmony
those egoic levels of separate entity
consciousness that are relentlessly
seeking
happiness in the external world
and that's why the greed the conspicuous
consumption
the jealousy the envy the anger the
cravings the aversions
whoops malevolence
happiness and the egoic separate self
entity are two mutually exclusive things
the egoic
separate self entity must dissolve
like a sugar cube in the hot tea of
infinite
consciousness in order for
happiness to be endogenous
not exogenous
and the other one time
the appearance of infinity everywhere
everything is finite we are finite
biological creatures
everything is time everything's based on
time there are time zones there's a
24-hour clock
everything has to be punctual and on
time these things serve
a purpose in the
day-to-day
when you schedule
to see somebody at
three o'clock want
to be on time you want them to be on
time that'd be nice
so it's cool to have that as well the
cycle of measuring
the orbits of the planet around the sun
and the rotation on its axis cool
great
never once are we taught in the
education system
about these illusions the
illusion of the ego the illusion of time
the illusion of
fear death separation illusion
deceptive appearance false belief
distortion of senses slash perceptions
of reality
generally shared by most people again
why can we clearly tell it's an illusion
it's a false belief that has absolutely
permeated
society at large
it's in service to us it's in service to
our enlightenments and service to our
awakening it's acting like a pressure
cooker
to get us to pierce the veil and
self-realize god realize
more and more people are now curious
what is atma vichara what is
self-inquiry
what is this self-realization or this
god realization that you speak of
what is this diamond necklace that is
already around my neck
what do you mean
that which you seek is what you are
seeking with what do you mean
that
consciousness that awareness that
knowingness
is it
it's just a big oneness the observer
and the physicalism those are not
separate things but they help
to be separated because we continuously
do it over and over again
the more that we separate physicalism
and consciousness or the observer
the more that we can at least say okay
look
we see a way that those two
actually are supposed to come together
into one there is only one
infinite creator there's one god one
source one infinity that this
is and this is how to get
beyond these deceptive appearances and
false beliefs of the ego
and time
all right i'm going to cluster these up
into two batches
the first batch is ego
the first thing is separation in ego
as long as you are a separate entity
as long as you have the notion that i am
a consciousness inside of a body
and that is it and i'm gonna die
as long as experiences are something
that
you're attached to that you have craving
for that you have aversion towards
there's gonna be perpetual cycle of
unhappiness
you can't be an egoic separate entity
there is no separation
there's just no separation
and it's interesting because a lot of
people live in multiplicity there's an
approximate
statistic that there's about 85 percent
of the planetary population
lives in some sort of a multiplicity
ah we believe in the individual we
believe in
the separate self entity
we'll unpack this in a moment but when
the
sugar cube of the separate self ego
dissolves in the hot tea of infinite
consciousness
you do not lose your individuation
you simply recognize that the i am-ness
of the consciousness
the awareness that is eternal and that
is infinite and that is being colored by
experience and we'll get to more of
these analogies here as we go
that that in itself is what you are
and that's why the idea of separation
is famously said to be consciousness
pretending to be a separate entity
so it's just the pretending to be a
separate entity the sugar cube
never even exists the separate egoic
self never exists
consciousness is always shining it's
like the sky or it's like the ocean it's
always shining even through the waves or
the clouds it's always there
it just remains for you to recognize
that diamond necklace around your neck
the diamond necklace around your neck is
the i am-ness of the ocean or the sky
but the quote egoic separate self is
caught up in the experiences of the
waves
caught up in the experiences of the
clouds how ridiculous is it
to see somebody out on the street
looking up at a cloud and yelling
curse you cloud i deserve better be
ridiculous
but now if you replace an emotion
with the cloud here people are
sitting and going curse you in motion i
deserve better
now you're starting to get a feel for it
it's ridiculous
love yourself accept yourself
exactly how this is
right now
recognize that that
ability for you
to become more at ease rather than
dis ease dis ease
is simply the egoic separate entity
lost in the clouds or the waves
here's the thing once that sugar cube
melts
of the egoic separate entity
you keep the individual
expressions of the waves and of the
clouds that are happening but you
recognize that you're the sky in the
ocean
we're doing a lot of intertwining
already with these points we'll also
touch on be here
the onion layers of identity is like a
contracted fist of fear
you know lao tzu and so many other
famous people have
talked about fear being the greatest
illusion there's nothing to fear
you're already at home you're already
god
this already is infinite consciousness
expressing itself
this is a formless absolute that's
expressing itself
infinitely in form again the ocean
expressing itself as waves the sky
expressing itself with clouds
the screen expressing itself with
applications
the paper expressing itself with words
how many more analogies do we need how
many more trips
to the amazon and all these different
places do we need in order to
take in the indigenous entheogens for us
to realize these very
simple investigations into the nature of
our experience
all it requires is an investigation an
honest
scientific investigation into the nature
of our experience do you ever experience
two things
when you put your hand on something you
know put your hand
on the computer or the phone that's in
front of you right now
i have it on the mic
is this sensation happening outside of
you
of your hand touching the computer or
the phone or the mic
is it happening inside of you where the
[ __ ] is the boundary
there is no boundary it's all
arbitrary all these boundaries are
arbitrary you can't even take
20 you can't even take one inhale
we take 20 000 of those a day you can't
even take one of those without
summoning the phytoplankton and trees
that are creating the photosynthesis
on a planetary level there's no
boundary there's no border it's an
absolute arbitrary
contraption that we've created
now does it serve us to say things like
ah
hey will you pass me that microphone
yeah it does
serve us to say that so we do use them
but we're not
lost in them that's the difference
so we're going to use the waves and
we're going to use this
the clouds and we're going to use the
words on the paper
or the applications on the screen
but we're not going to be lost in
a place where
we are coming from a non-self-realized
in a non-god-realized place
you have to realize the sky you have to
realize the ocean
first self-realization
as ramanu maharshi and so many other
people have said is the number one thing
that you can do period
and then that butterfly effects out
those layers of identity are
like a contracted fist right just
practice with me take your contracted
fist
imagine this as the ego as the separate
self
just contract your entire body along
with it right
this contract if this contracted body
and just get really tight tighten
everything up a lot
and then on three one two three release
release slowly release release
release your whole body release the
whole fist slowly
and take a deep breath
that is the natural unwinding of the
egoic separate self that is being
experienced across the world
and that's what the sufi metaphysics
meant by what
the unity of all finding
because it's a bunch of clenched
contracted
fists and bodies as egoic separate
selves that are slowly being unwound and
slowly
finding the diamond necklace that is
already around their neck
we've touched on this in episodes but
especially our direct path episodes
you can't jump and say that ah there's
nothing to seek
excellent
see doesn't work
you actually have to go under a process
where you do seek your ass off
it's not going to necessarily be a
single
ah done from an egoic place
it's definitely not going to take 30
years at monasteries anymore and it's
definitely not going to take
five years like it took me it's
shortening
that's why the direct path teachings are
so profound and they're so
quick and their metaphors are really
strong and they get people to
realize fast but
there's also a tremendous amount of
contemplative experience right
atmavichera
that we actually have to do
especially if you do things like
actually
take in the
the perennial spiritual wisdoms
which then give you different faces
up the mountain to the
one truth there are many paths and many
faces
up the mountain to the one truth of god
source
infinity the absolute one infinite
creator
every time that you look at those
different faces every time that you look
at those different paths what's
happening is that you're creating more
and more of a corpus
more and more of a lattice work where
you can interconnect the concepts
that enable you to understand what i and
my father are one
means or what asi
means you are that i am that we
are that
the kingdom of god is within you
there are myriad of these
but if none of them are in your lattice
work it's going to be a lot
harder for you to grasp the direct
path faster so to have a supplement
of the most profound spiritual wisdoms
that have ever been communicated as
these different faces up the mountain to
put them up in your latticework is going
to be really really helpful
again practice that activity like clench
your fist and clench your whole body and
then
and just let go and unwind that that is
basically what's happening with the
egoic separate self
and all of its onion layers of identity
think about how many layers of identity
do you have where are you in the range
there's the range it's all the way from
egoic consciousness
separate entity all the way to non-dual
awareness
where are you because if you're still
attached to all of your layers
that's inevitably going to bring lots of
fear because as soon as one person says
something like
you're not your name
oh i'm my name i'm where i was born
i'm my ethnicity i'm my job
my career my social media accounts
i am all of those things you see
the layers of identity create this
constricted
fist unwind it shed those layers
get to the pure bear empty awareness
that is eternal that is being colored
by the clouds by the waves by the words
by the applications
and that's when the sugar cube
actually begins
to dissolve in the hot tea
of the one infinite creator god source
the absolute humans are the portals
between the absolute of formlessness
and the quote physical form
we're the portals right in the middle
welcome
we've been doing this we're going to
continue doing this this never
ends it's an infinite exploration of
creation designs
is consciousness not enough for you
is awareness itself not enough for you
the very fact that you are aware or
sentient
or conscious you are undergoing a
process of
knowing and you're taking these
inhalations in some sort of a of a three
space
and there's a planet
and there's a sun and there's eight
billion other humans with this lineage
of a hundred billion humans that have
lived and died before us that built the
civilization and you can walk down the
street and you can get a slice of pizza
or you can go upstairs and you can
take a nap and get some deep sleep
is this experience not already profound
enough for you
does this already not bring enough off
for you what more could you
want than something like this
let that hit for a moment what more do
you
want than the profundity of what you're
already experiencing
happiness and the separate entity are
mutually exclusive
the happiness is not exogenous it's not
outside of you it's endogenous it's
internal
it's that diamond necklace already
around your neck your simple fact of
consciousness awareness
knowingness itself is the [ __ ] game
the world and the consciousness are not
two separate things they are one
thing science and spirituality are not
two things they are one thing
indigeneity and modernity are not two
things they are one thing
these things help in terms of giving a
little bit
of a juxtaposition
that's the point of saying clouds and
sky
it's a juxtaposition which helps our
understanding
of oh okay i get it now i'm the
infinite eternal sky that is
experiencing the modulations of the
clouds
that's why you create the duality or the
juxtaposition in order for people to get
it
but ultimately they're one there's no
border
of where the cloud stops and where the
sky
begins why don't you go and look for a
border
where the wave ends and where the ocean
starts
another way to think about it is are you
surfing
or are you literally fighting the waves
what are you doing
are you literally chilling on a
surfboard going like dude
ah this is dope look at this life look
at this reality
look at this consciousness yeah yeah
this is so
fun so many fun experiences
are you riding the wave
or are you literally fighting it are you
are you like ah
this this is not fair
this is mean i don't like this i want
something
else
just look at the juxtaposition there
which one do you want to be
do you want to surf or do you want to
fight the wave
what's going to happen is as that egoic
separate self
contracted fist dissolves
into the hot tea there's gonna be the
bliss police
this has been one of my favorite things
that channeled through it's been so
fascinating
it's like here take this bliss police
one i'm like okay this is dope
i l i laughed for like a couple
dozen minutes throughout the day
yesterday when it came through
because the bliss police is hilarious
because it's what happens it's like
another name for the ego is the bliss
police have you ever noticed that as
soon as you get a little bit more bliss
or a little bit peace maybe you're
tasting a little bit of
satori a little bit of enlightenment the
light is flickering a little
as soon as you're like a little bit more
blissed out and peaceful imperturbable
peace and causeless joy
the the bliss police the the ego
of all these other separate entities
ah you can't be like that you can't be
blissed out you can't be peaced out
oh you think you're untriggerable now
i'm going to trigger you
right this is the bliss police
are you going to be wise or are you
going to be a martyr
the more you have martyrdom towards
the egoic separate entities that are the
bliss police that are trying to
trigger you oh i'm just gonna jump right
in there and i'm gonna show them love
uh gracefully
gently distance yourself
namaste and
you're off you're not responsible
to go in and and unwind the contracted
fists to dissolve the sugar cubes
of the separate entities of the bliss
police
you're not responsible for that process
gracefully politely wisely distance
yourself
naturally the tendency is for
the separate entity of the contracted
fist of the ego
to gradually unwind
as it seeks ah happiness externally
let me fulfill my desire with more
greed and conspicuous consumption and
material
objects these things will make me happy
and naturally it goes [ __ ] that [ __ ]
didn't make me happy
how many more unhappy wealthy people do
we need to own the planet
how many more unhappy famous people
do we need on the planet are there not
enough
are there not enough
horrible cases of
mental health issues happening across
social media platforms
are there not enough incidents of
people feeling like they are being used
for their clout or for their money don't
we have enough examples of that
stop seeking externally the diamond
necklace is around your neck
yet it remains for you to recognize it
that's what piercing the veil is but you
can't just go
ah the diamond necklace is around my
neck done
again it doesn't work that way
you actually have to go through a
process of self-inquiry
but as you do you will literally feel
a well of honey that is underneath of
this rock
that is imperturbable peace that is
causeless joy
that is [ __ ] on nonda existence
consciousness bliss
okay
now
all right
so we chunked up that first one on
ego time death fear and separation the
great illusions
we covered ego separation
and fear in that first chunk now we're
gonna cover
time and death and a lot of other things
here in the
second chunk so
the first thing to recognize about time
is to absolutely
destroy it completely destroy it the
first thing that you have to do is
destroy it
because
it's not to say that you're not gonna
show up to that three o'clock meeting
on time because you've destroyed time
that's not the point
again the middle path the middle way but
you have to destroy
the illusion of time to start right time
is like the sugar cube as well you have
to dissolve it
first in order to self-realize and then
from there you can find the middle path
where you
have literally tasted god tasted the
self-realization and you recognize that
you
are that and you still
as ramen maharishi said you
are sahaja samadhi
and that
is the ability to hold your
meditative self-realization
consciousness of nondual awareness while
you do your daily
activities and that means time
but you have to self-realize first so
first is destroy
time destroy the illusion of time sit
there and look at your phone clock
or at the computer clock or even better
look at the actual moving hands
of an actual clock and go and look at
the second hand and the minute hand and
the hour hand
and when you look at them recognize how
illusory they are
they're deceptive it's a false belief
completely indoctrinated on us
and it's very similar with the birth and
the death fallacy as well
obviously as the
one infinite creator expresses itself in
these creation designs
inevitably it's going to have some sort
of a mechanism we're going to have a
a mechanism where there's a quote birth
and a quote death
imagine if there was no quote birth or
quote death what would happen
you would literally be eternal and
infinite
so there would be no game
you get it there would be no game
that's why birth and death have to
happen
that's why time and the illusion of it
has to happen
the illusion affinity finite
has to happen that's what creates
the game that the one infinite creator
plays
the absolute formlessness
creates the
infinite physical
creation designs where we immerse
ourselves into it as
the i am ness of
conscious agents agents of this one
awareness
there has to be a birth and a death
otherwise you would be eternal and
infinite
and there would be no veil to pierce so
there has to be a birth and a death it
actually logically makes sense
i know there are some computer
scientists and engineers over there that
are like oh [ __ ]
[ __ ] that does make sense duh
so this is literally a feature
birth and death are a feature of our
creation designs
but we're indoctrinated to believe that
that's
completely the birth and the death of
our consciousness
it is not the birth and the death of our
consciousness there is no birth and no
death of consciousness consciousness is
the ocean
you are experiencing the wave
you are the wave of an 80-year
expression
of the ocean
if you're starting to feel
as though these concepts are resonating
these are very much like the teachings
of the direct
path so again i highly recommend
watching our videos on our channel on
the direct path
we're tuning into the myriad of the
direct path teachers that we've been
recommending
on our channel as well reading their
books watching their videos
to know that you are the ocean
or you are the sky that is eternal
and that its nature is bliss in peace
and that it's being
colored by this clouds and by the waves
of experience that's what the non-dual
awareness is the pupil if you look at
another person's pupil the pupil is
shared
right the iris around the pupil
is your unique wave that you're writing
but the pupil itself is the pupil of god
of the one infinite creator that we all
are that we all share in rumi's quote
about you go from room to room looking
for the diamond necklace that is already
around your neck
you could replace that with pupil
you go from room to room looking for the
pupil
that is already in your [ __ ] eye
ah happiness happiness external yeah
yeah yeah
nah it's your pupil your
consciousness is it
so next time you look at people's pupils
go and do an experience an activity
right now where you stop
with a friend family member what not
pause hi i would like to do a couple
minute activity
where we just look at each other's
pupils in complete silence
without laughing
this is what is meant by eye gazing
this goes a lot deeper than oh
i had a moment
that was revelatory that's great that's
a good step
but literally pierce that and go even
deeper i am literally looking at the
pupil of god
and the same god is looking at my
pupil which is another pupil of god it
is
one infinite creator that is expressing
itself through these expressions
of waves in the ocean that are then
looking at themselves
looking at itself from two angles
there's all these different ways to
explain the same thing
all we're doing is we're talking about
the different paths
or the different faces up the one
mountain of truth
many paths but their end is one
you have so many of these different
options to tackle this birth and death
fallacy
you were this awareness and this
consciousness
quote before you were born and you're
going to be this awareness in this
consciousness
after you die
how much more simple can it be you have
to have this logically
you have to have the birth and death
fallacy logically
if it didn't exist you would be eternal
and infinite and there would be no game
to play there would be no veil to pierce
there would be no quote awakening or
enlightenment or self-realization or god
realization
it's all embedded in the game it's part
of the game it's part of the expression
the wave must realize that it is
made of the oceanic water
and we feel the illusion of time when
we're in flow or when we're using
entheogens
i haven't felt a moment of time while
doing this
stream i'm just in pure
raw flow zero time none
doesn't exist
when you're doing something that you
absolutely adore
time doesn't exist you're just in flow
that is the feeling of eternity wake up
you know the surfer that's cruising on
the wave and having an exceptional time
doesn't recognize time
same thing with entheogens
unleashing god within
unleashing the divine within and theogen
the entheogens capacity to
take the contracted egoic separate
entity fist
and just dissolve it like the sugar cube
in the hot tea
of infinity happens
and it's beautiful and it's happened to
me several times across
different entheogens and it's been
extremely profound
but there literally needs to be a
profound reflection
on the oceanic-ness that was experienced
in order to re-baseline to non-dual
awareness otherwise
the contraction can happen again
although it's a little bit looser
you know anthogens in a sense are like
bathing in the loosening
of the
egoic separate entity
but you don't feel time you don't you
don't feel
time there is no time when your
sugar cube is dissolved in the oceanic
infinitude
that's why anthogens are so powerful
also there's a past present future game
that you can play
again this doesn't exist there is no
past present or future there is just
this happening
there's just this
so again what we're doing is we're
creating a juxtaposition of
well past present and future ha ha to
play a game
right all you have to do
is you play a game with again your
friend
family co-worker whoever you want
play the game you take three
little circles or squares
that are like little papers you put
one you put the words past on one
present on another and future on the
other
right little circles or squares so past
present and future
one on each and then you tell your
family friend or co-worker
family friend or co-worker whoever to
sort them in a way that
they feel is right
and just sit there and watch
watch how many people stack the past
and the present and the future one after
the other
we're just brainwashed by the illusion
of time
true simultaneous key meaning that
what an enlightened person does and when
they actually have this embodied
truly embodied right not just doing this
to ha proved a point no
you actually truly know the illusion of
time what you do is you
stack the past the present
and the future on top of one another you
stack all three circles
or all three squares on top of each
other
instead of in a line
so there's another little game for you
to play
and true simultaneity is when you've
experienced self-realization or god
realization of the illusion of time
and the stacking of the past present and
future
but then you also know how to show up to
that three o'clock meeting
because you're again sahaja you're
taking it with
you in your daily activities
play that game it's a critical one it's
a fun one
and it'll slowly again loosen up the
contracted fist of time
dissolve it in the hot tea
and that's how you taste eternity
that's what this is this is eternal this
is infinite this is not
finite this is not
this is not a biological creature having
a conversation to other biological
creatures this is an oceanic infinite
awareness consciousness
communicating with itself across
little portals of pupils
and there is no across it just
is one big ocean
okay again ego time death fear
and separation the greatest delusions
ego and time are the two heaviest
anchors holding people back from god
self-realization
illusion again deceptive appearance
false belief a distortion of senses
perceptions of reality
generally shared by most people
ego broken up into that separation those
layers of identity like a contracted
fist practice that exercise of unwinding
breathing and relaxing the contracted
fist like a big sugar cube
that's just dissolving in the hot tea of
the ocean
or the sky recognize the juxtaposition
between the waves
and the clouds as well as comparing that
to the ocean
and the sky and then
recognize that the bliss police come and
to gracefully wisely
create that
end time the birth death fallacy
flow entheogens past present future game
to play
and anchoring eternity
instead of anchoring time and anchoring
the ego which are holding us back from
self and god realization learn how to
anchor
god the kingdom of god within you learn
how to anchor eternity how to anchor
infinity how to anchor the formless the
agentless the attributeless
absolute and we've made
direct path videos on that if you'd like
to check those out in more detail
so that's it again these are the
greatest delusions
these are the heaviest anchors
just go look at what's happening right
now it's horrible it's a
massive polarization propaganda
of oh my god this political party this
oh my god that political party that
oh my god you should live in fear of the
virus oh my god you should live in fear
because of geopolitical war oh my god
you should live in fear
fear fear fear it's like a big drum that
is being played fear
fear fear fear do you know how to
literally recognize that drum being
played
and say that you bow to the divine
in it namaste and that you go to the
drum that's beating
of love of light of wisdom
of bliss of peace because that drum is
beating
everywhere every moment it's beating
just like your heart
what are you paying attention to are you
paying attention
to fear and ego and separation
and time and death or are you paying
attention to the drum
that's being played of love
and light and peace and bliss
and prosperity well-being abundance
flourishing maximizing society's
potential
and ultimately those two different drums
are transcended in one
but to have discernment is crucial
to undergo that process of
self-realization
distance yourself from these greatest
delusions recognize them have
discernment
love you very much thanks for tuning in
let me know your feelings in the
comments below i'd love to hear where
you're at in your journey
and
like the video share it with people that
you think this would resonate with
subscribe if you haven't we've been
getting a good chunk of new
subscribers as well as new people that
are commenting
talking about how profoundly the channel
has
influenced them which is fantastic and
i've been replying saying i'm extremely
grateful for that
i love that super grateful
and
if you like what we're doing here we
have a lot of goals we had a call with
a animation school
this morning
about chimps our animated series around
it's like a pedagogy for
self-realization
for younger people for gen z gen alpha
and so if you want to support things
like that and all of our other endeavors
all of our links are in the bio below
you can also support in the live chat
and donate there but you can donate
directly to us with the links in the
live chat
in the bio so love you lots
thank you so much and
that's it
peace
relax and unwind the clenched fist
of the egoic separate entity and
dissolve it
like the sugar cube in the hot tea
of infinite consciousness